[Music]
in our school matters series we're
looking at the effort to keep students
from dropping out because of the
pandemic nationwide
it's estimated about 3 million students
are unaccounted for
and the experts fear that that could
have long-term consequences for their
education
we visited sunset high school that's in
dallas which is an area that is hard hit
by this pandemic
educators in the districts are trying to
track down more than 9
000 high school students nine thousand
who stopped attending classes there
maria villarreal shows us one student's
struggle
to just stay on track i love going to
school
just for the interactions and getting
along with everyone else but
something about teaching was just so
different and something very unique
that i was like i might as well give it
a shot so you want to be a teacher
yes before the pandemic luis borja
enrolled in sunset high school
to take advantage of their college
credit program but in the midst of covid
before his senior year
luis decided to start working did you
want to help out your family
i wanted to you know they said you don't
have to do it but i was like
you know there's bills that need to be
paid but i also want to learn how to
take
responsibility you know and be
independent
but balancing work in online summer
classes caused luis to fall behind with
his schoolwork
and he was placed on academic dismissal
i thought my world came
crashing down that day because it was
four years you know work we just
continued to encounter different types
of problems that we
really weren't prepared for principal
claudia vega has been working with
students
including luis to get them back on track
and back in school
you know we're missing anywhere from 15
to 20 percent
and the failure rate is 15 to 20 percent
and
we've got to find a way to bring them
back we've got to enrollment sits at
2100 students
but today even though the school has
been fully open
for in-person learning since the fall
just 279
kids have shown up we tied along with
dallas isd administrators
as a search for high school students
that had disappeared during the pandemic
more than nine thousand total including
more than fifteen hundred seniors the
reason we're going and making these
visits is to let them know
that we understand and that we have
programs in place to help them
across the country it's estimated that
schools have lost contact
with more than three million students
during the pandemic
unfortunately none of the five houses we
were not able to make any contact we're
going to get these kids back in school
at some point we're getting them back in
school that same grit
is what created a new norm at sunset
high school
i think that we've learned a lot in this
past year and a half
we've learned to be flexible we've
learned that kids
like to have more choices one of those
choices includes online learning during
the day
but also offering a homework hub from
five to seven at night
that's staffed with rotating teachers
like our education system hasn't changed
in
generations right like decades and so
our teachers had always kind of said
let's do something different
let's try and then we were forced into
this opportunity where
you just had to how do you call it an
opportunity
um oh my goodness
what is it that makes makes you so
emotional about this we've had
oh give me one second of course we've
had
employees hospitalized we've had
students
hospitalized we've our students
um have suffered they've struggled
they've lost parents they've lost
siblings um we had a family that
lost four members in their immediate
family
and students in 10th grade and we're
trying to convince them to stay in
school
how do you do that every way possible
and principal vega's persistence paid
off
luis is now back on track set to
graduate with a high school
and associates degree this may would you
say maybe the pandemic
forced you to become a better student
yes
it made me become a student that i never
realized i could be
you know i knew i always could be
independent
but i didn't know what motivation i
needed what needed to light up me up
to do it you know overall yes it shaped
me up into a
whole different person but i'd say
not a negative way in a better way for
cbs this morning
mideagle dallas oh
boy i hope other kids make the same
choice to go back yeah stakes are so
high
it's been such a tough year for
everybody everybody for the kids for the
teachers yeah